bonjour joaquim pueyo merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france on parlait
à l'instant de ces municipalités prix
court un peu par le protocole sanitaire
et notamment les investissements dans
les équipements d'aération
comment ça se présente concrètement pour
vous à alençon
écoutez nous annoncions nous avons 100
classes et on procède à la ventilation
mécanique c'est à dire que avant que les
années les élèves rentrent dans la
classe où nous bien évidemment on aère
on ventile à chaque mouvement il ya une
motivation mécanique qui se met en place
le ministère recommande malgré tout
qu'on puisse détecter la teneur de co2
dans les cas ce qui permet de savoir si
fictivement l'air a été bien ventilé
renouvelé c'est ce qu'on va faire
d'ailleurs on va acheter des détecteurs
de co2 quant aux halles à la technique
pour purifier l'air c'est compliqué
parce que ce sont des appareils qui
coûte 1500 euros il fait faire des
marchés publics il ya la maintenance
donc en l'état nous on procède
uniquement à la ventilation mécanique et
on suit à la lettre le protocole qui a
été bien évidemment établi par le
gouvernement et qu'on applique
concrètement gel lavage des mains
légalement ventilation portes du masque
donc on a quand même un site enfin le
département de meta département qui
n'est pas trop impacté pour l'instant
pour le virus nous sommes en zone jaune
en quelque sorte donc le protocole sera
suivie d'une manière stricte alors
forcément passer pour en mettant en
place des des purificateurs d'air à
quelques jours de la rentrée vous
parliez de ces détecteurs de co2 et des
100 classes dans votre municipalité
est ce que toutes les classes l'avant
une semaine seront équipés seront seront
prêtes pour accueillir les élèves avec
les recommandations du gouvernement
d'une part pour l'instant c'est pas
obligatoire le ministère souhaite
effectivement que les écoles soient
équipés de détecteurs de ces deux ci
n'est pas obligatoire si une
recommandation mais nous on va
s'orienter vers l'achat des détecteurs
pour l'instant on applique le même
protocole que la belgique et au mois de
juin août c'est le même c'est-à-dire
ventiler les locaux d'une manière
systématique et le permettent
effectivement
aux enfants d'avoir une distanciation
dans les glaces dans les cantines éviter
le brassage parce qu'on sait très bien
que pressage est un des facteurs
déterminants pour le virus une cuve ce
véhicule vous le disiez un les
équipements pour l'instant ne sont pas
obligatoires en tout cas une annonce qui
a fait quand même une semaine avant la
rentrée des classes est ce que vous
regrettez peut-être ce manque
d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement qui vous donne finalement
presque seulement une semaine pour vous
organiser oui c'est vrai que j'aurais pu
anticiper davantage mais bon nous
annonçons l'été mais des prêts en fait
d'appliquer protocoles tels que
d'annoncer le gouvernement c'est
compliqué c'est difficile je pense qu'il
ya une mobilisation des personnels une
mobilisation également des enseignants
et puis il ya une prise de conscience
également des parents d'élèves je pense
que les parents doivent effet témoin de
vigilants pour leurs enfants s'ils ont
un peu de fièvre ils sont un peu de
symptômes voilà je crois qu'il ya toute
une intrigue collectif qui doit être
fait un travail de prévention est
essentiellement un travail de
l'information également mais la
collectivité est prête pour accueillir
dans les bonnes conditions de sécurité
de santé l'ensemble des élèves de la
ville d'alençon nous avons 100 classes
de 2000 élèves donc c'est quand même
important et on va effectivement ce qui
est important c'est de déterminer la
teneur
du renouvellement delà dans les classes
et je passe le détecteur de ces deux
d'une bonne technique pour apprécier si
l'air a été bien renouveler donc c'est
pour ça qu'on doit s'équiper
les lecteurs de ces 2,2 un premier temps
de manière movie qu'on pourra cas des
tests puis ensuite demeura généralisée
des banshee une semaine avant la rentrée
scolaire est ce que vous avez déjà des
retours des enseignants des directeurs
des directrices d'école sur cette
rentrée ce qu'ils sont inquiets
justement quant au retour des élèves au
retour de tout ce brassage et
d'éventuelles contaminations
je sais pas si une étude je pense qu'il
ya une prise de conscience dans leurs
propres responsabilités moi j'ai
rencontré effectivement des directeurs
d'école la semaine dernière où je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de sérénité parmi les
enseignants parmi les parents d'élèves
également donc ce qu'on soit extrêmement
vigilant des galets septembre bien sûr
on voit les signaler et on ferme à la
classe comme le protocole exige donc je
croise une prise de conscience est déjà
quiétude bien évidemment parce que le
virus il sait très bien les conséquences
mais estime même le fera et qu'il ya une
grande responsabilité de la part des
enseignants et de la part des personnels
moi j'ai interrogé les personnes la
plupart sont vaccinés d'ailleurs est
bien de le rappeler
c'est obligatoire mais c'est bien le
rappeler également vous savez que dans
l'orne on a plus de 80 % d'habitants ont
été vaccinées c'est quand même le
premier département français en terme de
vaccination donc qui veut dire que quand
même plus de protection nous notre
département dans les départements où la
population innue back side et ça c'est
quand même très positif à le dire pour
les adultes comme pour les élèves comme
pour les enfants
merci beaucoup je me souviens d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin à sur rt france
rappelle que vous êtes maire d'alençon
merci beaucoup